we're telling people and suggest
everybody trying to educate people on us
Aviation is in a different place in
other industries other industries if
there's no agreement in March 2019 we'll
fall back on the world trade agreements
we do not we've always been carved out
we're subject to different bilateral and
multilateral agreements that provide the
legal framework under which we fly all
those flights to the UK all the flights
to the you and all the flights to the UK
onward to VU without that legal
framework we can't fly the cargo can't
come in and get shipped forward with all
the parts needed in Europe or the parts
needed here so the planes die on the
ground it's as simple as that yeah
hopefully it's not that simple our
belief in our hope is that the economic
imperative
given what aviation means to the UK
economy the US economy in the EU economy
will lead to a quicker conclusion right
now the EU is committed to making it one
big negotiation and I think that's the
stance that that Great Britain is taking
as well we don't believe we can afford
to be part of one great big pot that
needs to be stirred over the next 20
months now we clearly have some big
transatlantic alliances British Airways
and American Airlines left-hander and
United for example Air France and Delta
what would be the implication for those
alliances those alliances were created
under the legal framework under which we
currently fly the EU US Open Skies
agreement without that legal framework
again those alliances could come under
attack and those alliances are
responsible for creating an awful lot of
travel that did not exist before a great
degree of connectivity I just came from
Madrid and you know there are 12 million
visitors from Great Britain to Spain
every single year that's replicated
across the EU in various places and
without the kind of connectivity that
exists under these alliances that might
not happen now you've been travelling
around why it's all you've been is a
number-10 you've been to the Department
of exiting the EU what sort of response
are you getting from policy makers
positive positive
they understand that aviation is
different I do think though with all the
other issues involved you know the
payment citizens here at all the other
industries it's a big plate and a lot to
chew on very quickly
so our purpose is to make sure that
everyone understands and acts on the
fact because you do have to act on the
fact that aviation is different because
we all rely on it you know where I grew
up nobody used to fly and the 60s and
70s then in the 80s people start flying
more and everybody flies now it's like a
public utility and many people's mind
it's there they expect it if it's not
there they're going to be very unhappy